[Musique]
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir une mère hors
du commun ça c'est début des années 60
voici la famille hors du commun de la
star du music-hall joséphine baker douze
enfants adoptés aux quatre coins du
monde une famille universelle qu'elle
installe au château des milandes dans le
périgord noir acquis au bouillon est
l'aîné de la fratrie à 69 ans il revient
aujourd'hui sur l'idéal de sa mère j'ai
eu cette idée car ce que j'ai vu
tellement de l trempé tensions entre les
êtres humains des soi-disant adultes et
j'étais sûr qu'avec mes petits-enfants
innocent il pourrait bien exemple absolu
de la fraternité et mondial on devait
servir de preuve tangible
de ce que de ce qu'elle avance et c'est
à dire que partir de différence on
arrive à créer une unicité
[Musique]
gnl c'est une période de ma vie que je
chéris oui effectivement on était tous
ce qui est normal avec des copains votre
enfance elle était marqué où les par le
rythme et de le quotidien de tout enfant
militante anti raciste joséphine baker
était de tous les combats à travers le
monde mais quand elle revenait aux
milandes elle se consacrait
exclusivement à ses enfants c'était une
âme une maman qui était sourd absente
mais d'essayer de compenser
c'est la vie qui fait ça nan sandé
parier part des autres mamans de
l'époque où d'aujourd'hui qui
travaillent
en 1964 dans une chanson joséphine baker
rendait hommage à sa tribu arc en ciel
qui sont couleurs de la nuit
d'autres couleurs du jour d'autres coups
là le soleil et d'auto plus
ils sont tous en jeu tous et mon coeur
de maman
les aime tous autant au moment où
le champ de cette chanson
on s'aperçoit vraiment vraiment que
cette famille qu'a construit qui dit qui
est pratiquement fait
lui tient à coeur
et elle est loin de se douter que
quelques cinquante ans après six années
60 ans cette famille est bas elle a
réussi la fraternité universelle rêvé
par joséphine baker est aujourd'hui mise
à l'honneur
c'est l'une des raisons de sa
panthéonisation n aurait certainement
pas refuser le portillon maintenant elle
aurait accepté mais en disant attention
bomono rémois mais à travers moi vous
aurez tous ceux qui oeuvrent dans
l'ombre je suis fier d'eux moment un
bourg houlette de votre mère
[Musique]
oh